in this series we'll be discussing heme
and its metabolism and in this video
we're gonna sort of introduce he okay
heme is an important component of the
globins okay which are specifically
hemoglobin and myoglobin which we've
talked about before okay
heme is also an important component of
the cytochromes hey the cytochromes
which of course we saw in the electron
transport chain okay they're also an
important component of cy p450 enzymes
now he has farted structure which is
shown below here contains it contains
really two key elements or two key
components and the first component is
the porphyrin ring the porphyrin ring
and I'll put a little one here so that's
one key component and that porphyrin
ring can have side chains as we could
see down here but the porphyrin ring is
basically this portion here we'll talk
more about it later the the that
basically that part inside there is the
the porphyrin ring and then these guys
on the outside are the the side chains
okay and you would notice the side
chains vary depending on which team you
have okay so I'm going to get rid of
some of that green stuff so you know a
little bit messy
but yeah it's got that porphyrin ring
and then on the inside there we also
have the iron two plus ion in the center
okay those are really the two key
components that we think about that make
up heme so in the center here we have
heme B which is protoporphyrin 9 and
iron 2 plus and so portal porphyrin 9 is
a specific porphyrin and he and B is
what we typically think about when we
think about him is that's because that's
the heme that's in hemoglobin and in
myoglobin we have he may and heme see
here also just to kind of show you
different structures but he may for
example is he is in cytochrome
cytochrome a of complex for the electron
transport chain and then him see over
here is in cytochrome C of complex 3 of
the electron transport chain okay and
you can see how they have these
different
side-chains you know that make them
unique as far as team goes okay anyway
so that's what's going on there now heme
is made in most tissues but we mostly
care about what's going on as far as its
synthesis in the liver and the red blood
cell precursors in the bone marrow okay
you'll notice I'm writing precursors
here in all caps and that's that's
important okay so liver and bone marrow
and in the bone marrow when these red
blood cell precursors the heme synthesis
sort of occurs at a constant rate and
that's basically due just to sort of
general globin turnover whereas in the
liver that occurs in a more variable
rate depending on what's going on with
the different heme proteins okay that in
the body particularly cyp 450 which
we'll talk about more about later now
why did I write red blood cell
precursors in all caps we will see
momentarily but it has to do with what I
wrote in purple there in the cells there
are reactions as far as heme synthesis
goes there are in the pathway of heme
synthesis there are reactions that
occurring that occur in the mitochondria
and reactions that occur out in the
cytosol okay and that's important okay
because and that deals with the fact
that he miz only made in red blood cell
precursors and not in mature red blood
cells okay why is that well it's because
you